the Robert small editor of a new book
that will be published on Monday the
responsibilities of journalism let me
read a quote from your book and get your
reaction to it there are good men and
women who will not stand for office
concern that you will find their flaws
or invent them this comment is directed
to the general men and gentle women of
the press
many people have dealt with you wish
they had not you are capricious and
unpredictable you are fearsome and you
are feared because there is never any
way to know whether this time you will
be fair and accurate or whether you will
not and there is virtually nothing we
can do about it I think that that really
summarizes the perception of many people
about the the news media today they
think they're insensitive intrusive
arrogant if you will and in the realm of
public affairs many people feel as
though they have to undergo an x-ray
process to become involved in in
political life and I think the knowledge
of that knowing what they will have to
go through makes them somewhat hesitant
to to become involved good evening we
are back live this time with Professor
Robert small he is the editor of this
book which will be published on Monday
by University of Notre Dame Press Notre
Dame press the responsibilities of
journalism and it is how did the book
come to be the book is the result of a
conference that Notre Dame conducted and
it was funded by the Gannett foundation
and what we did is we tried to broaden
the discourse about the concerns ethical
concerns about journalism and by broaden
the discourse what I mean is that we
invited people who were not only
journalists but people who were in
journalism education in business in
government in philosophy and in theology
to come to Notre Dame and to talk about
journalism in its moral context and
after the conference we asked the the
featured speakers to go back and to
write essays
and to bring them together into one
volume and that is this book we're
talking about what conclusion did you
draw after the conference there were
several several different conclusions I
think probably the most important one
was that journalists today need to be
much more aware of the consequences of
their acts that that they need to be
aware of the motivation for what they do
they need to be aware of the techniques
of their of their craft or their
profession but primarily the
consequences that they do have an impact
on the people that they cover and on
their audience and they should keep that
in mind as well as trying to break a
story let's be aware of what that story
might signify and mean to a larger
audience by the way to our audience our
phone lines are open let me tell you
what the phone numbers are area code two
one nine two three four two seven eight
eight if you are a resident of the state
of Indiana and for everybody else area
code two one two three four to seven
fluoro as soon as the as soon as you get
a ringing sound stay with us because
that means you've got your place in line
and we'll pick up the phone when we're
just about ready to put you on the air
and the subject this hour is kind of a
continuation of the last hour more of
the issues surrounding journalism man
we've got a man who's spent some time
studying that subject for the next hour
and we hope to have you participate in
our discussion with him do you like
journalists oh sure and I was one for
for several years liking journalists is
not the question trying to figure out
ways in which journalism can operate to
illuminate the society in a more
meaningful way and to be responsible as
they go about their work those are the
those are the issues there's nothing
finer than the Free Press in the United
States but what we are seeing is this
this assault on the press because of the
perception that
that some members of it that some are
arrogant and intrusive and what I think
this book suggests is that we need to be
aware of our publics and the the way in
which the the messages from the media
might have an impact on you were a
journalist now in the press a million
newspaper yes
what kind of newspaper worked at a small
newspaper in this state in Indiana as I
was growing up and then for several
years as I was going through college and
in graduate school I worked for a wire
service and did quite a bit of work for
a larger metropolitan newspapers there's
two kinds of presses the print and is
electronic is there a fundamental
difference between the two in terms of
the kinds of issues you've discussed in
this book I would say that it's
important to discriminate that many of
the examples that the public talks about
in terms of sensationalism for example
many of those are more the examples come
from broadcasting the one that that many
people cite is the one where the the
marine comes in to tell the the family
that that the son has been killed and
there is a camera crew right behind the
behind the marine there is that aspect
to it but clearly when you have
instances like the Janet Cooke case and
the fabricated story in the New York
Times Magazine and the problems that
case now pending concerning the Wall
Street Journal the ethics of print
journalists are worth our discussion as
well
what is the we're going to take some
phone calls in just a second but we're
going to hear from a lot of consumers of
the news and our audience is as a
voracious has a voracious appetite for
news 96% of the Merina daily newspaper
they watch the network what do you
expect to hear tonight what is the most
common complaint
you expect you're gonna hear tonight and
what have you uncovered in your research
the most common complaint that I hear is
why is there so much bad news and right
after that why are the various news
institutions so biased and you're gonna
test me on this aren't you well we're
gonna find out right now because the
first call and this will be the first of
many we hope Norfolk Virginia go ahead
please news media bias could it be
because of the people perceive it as
being biased because of the things that
they report like right now they're
reporting about so many people are being
hungry and some people just don't want
to know about that could it could that
have any bearing on what they're
thinking
I think bias is is usually in the eye of
the beholder there are many people who
would say that the news media in general
are are biased Irving Kristol in The
Wall Street Journal the other morning
had a long piece to that to that effect
John Swearengen in this book that we're
talking about makes the same makes the
same charge my perception is that that
the bias might not be an ideological one
or a political one but more in line of
an organizational bias which means that
in the case of of television that that
they go after the visual story they go
after the story with conflict they go
after the story that they can resolve to
their own satisfaction in in just a few
seconds and I think the organizational
bias rather than a large conspiracy of
ideological bias is more to the point of
of what we're talking about professor
robert small has edited a book called
the responsibility of journalism and
that is the subject of the rest of this
hour i want to stick my neck out a
little bit here and say that ask the
audience maybe we can't hear from some
working journalists both print
or electronic to see what personal
stories they might have to offer this
our next call is from Cleveland Ohio go
ahead hello hi can you hear me loud and
clear ma'am go right ahead well I've
been watching this I'm a first-time
caller congratulations might have you I
enjoy it very much but I am very happy I
got through tonight because I was
completely beside myself when I heard
some of the questions that were called
in or some of the comments that were
made regarding social security first I
want to say I have worked with the
Social Security Administration for 21
years and if anyone has any doubt -
scaring the old people they better check
back on their fact ma'am can I interrupt
you for just a second I know you might
have been trying to get in for a couple
weeks
you've happened to get a program where
we're talking about journalism and the
news media in general how about if you
take your concern about Social Security
and give us a press slant on it all
right the only thing I want to say is
that when President Reagan wanted to cut
the a as the percentage of the age plus
a couple other things that gap was
closed in 24 hours there was such a
deluge of people calling in he couldn't
he he's the one that did it and I know
because our directives came in right in
from the White House to our office as to
what their it we had an advance on that
the other thing is I I just I would
never ever vote I mean according to the
press and one thing in another when
they're asking questions I would never
vote for any politician that tried to
impose his religious views on to me and
my question is though why hasn't the
press ever asked why didn't they ever
call the federal workers regarding the
president
okay ma'am thank you very much Robert
smooth
I'm not sure I can answer that question
but what what I would like to know and
it's related to your concern is why
hasn't the the news media been more
responsible in dealing with an issue
like the the presidential debates the
coverage after the debates focused on
who won and who lost who was up who was
down who was tired who was fresh and I
think what the American people need from
the news media after an event like that
is some probing of the of the statements
that were made made there were several
charges made by President Reagan and by
former vice president Mondale they were
in conflict and to me that a primary
responsibility of journalism in an
election year is to try to clarify those
those issues I'd like to see that and I
think you'd like to see the other four
Indiana residents the number is two one
nine two three four to seven eight eight
and everybody else two one nine two
three four two seven four oh let's take
the next call from South Bend go ahead
yeah first of all I'd like to thank
c-span for giving you the opportunity to
well this is a grassroots movement and
this is a grassroots telephone call
right from South Penn I'd like to ask
mr. Neal is that right
small professors normal yeah are you
familiar with the we have a one local
paper or self in Tribune what do you
feel is the slant conservative liberal
where do you slap that South Bend
Tribune now what impact do you feel it
has on local voters tell you what Carl
why don't you give us your own opinion
first okay
definitely conservative
do you see that in the editorial page
only from the front page through the
editorials okay anything else I feel as
though the impact is great I could mr.
smilk comment on that okay thank you I
think that that certainly with any
newspaper and the the South Bend Tribune
is is our paper here every newspaper
like that has the the power to make us
think about certain issues and to make
us think about certain people in that
sense that's a that's a very important
influence and power I would tend to
agree with your judgement on the
editorial page I would not agree in
terms of the news coverage I think that
the the South Bend Tribune makes an
effort to keep the two departments
separate and they do something else that
I wish more newspapers would do and that
is to label some of their stories as
analysis and some of the others as as
straight news so that a reader has the
the knowledge of the kind of information
coming to him or her quickly professor
before we take our next call say
something positive a positive trend
about the print or electronic media that
you see I think that it a very positive
trend is that it is acquainting us with
with many things instantaneously we're
not in the dark about about anything I
think that that we do have guideposts
that we can that we can follow I'm just
asking for a little bit more in the way
of taking us down the path okay we want
to get a lot of calls in because I know
people feel strongly about this next
call is from Canton Ohio go ahead hi
my question is concern in the news media
and the debates and morality and that
moves me there so far as fails to point
out that Ronald Reagan made the
statement during the debates with mr.
Mondale that under the Constitution we
are guaranteed life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness now this man is the
president of the United States and he
doesn't know the Constitution from the
Declaration of Independence and none of
the news media has reported this yet and
my second point is now the church
Catholic the church is also opposed to
two pillars and stealing mr. Reagan is a
divorced man his wife was pregnant two
months before he married her and the
church is also against stealing now mr.
Reagan is stealing from the poor to get
the rich would you please comment on
this please I think that the first part
of your question was is related to what
I was mentioning just a couple of
moments ago that my reading of the
coverage after the debate was that too
much of it was caught up in the horse
race and that we have these occasions
now so-called debates they're really
joint appearances as we well know but
after those appearances we ought to
receive from the news media the
clarification on the issues that that
are raised during those periods let's
get away from these polls polls are easy
journalism let's do some more difficult
to work what about focus groups you
mentioned that in your book or though it
was some of the participants do is that
a legitimate journalistic technique it's
legitimate it's legitimate but I think
that there are other ways and that you
can only do so much of that
and then finally it it's not as
satisfactory for your for the public as
as some of the other kinds of journalism
yeah they go too far they find something
and then they'll they'll continue it and
I'm saying let's have some more
perspective is there one thing if you
could change one thing about the evening
news what would it be what would it be
it would be longer how much longer give
him 60 minutes do you think it would
happen
I'm sure what happened and I know that
one of the things that Walter Cronkite
did during his last year was to take two
pilot programs the network's sincerely
want to do it and the local affiliates
won't allow Indianapolis Indiana your
necks go ahead yes investigating journal
and so forth I'd like for you to take
forgetting was raised how boy went to
school if he went to high school or not
or if he went to college and what
college I also like to check and find
out what the American Activities
Committee on their investigation when he
was president of the Union not there the
news Actors Guild what they found out
about it and what they done about it
oh hang up well Karl hold on don't go
away do you happen to know the answers
of some of these questions yes oh oh
yeah we've got you all right you want to
share them with us all right nobody on
c-span or any committee ever bring up
his education or anything about the UH
no American
Activities Committee that he I know he
was investigated not why I don't know
and what they found out I don't know
okay thanks for the call it's hard to
believe that the president has covered
as he is do you have any response to
what he thinks are gaps in the press
coverage I think that probably the
source of some of the information that
he would like would be a biography
called Reagan that lukannon who's the
White House correspondent of The
Washington Post wrote the president went
to Eureka College was a economics major
and then went into went into radio the
other aspect of the question I can't
can't address some of this though some
of this I think is related to what what
the people were talking about during the
last program which is the the art of
controlled access and this
administration in particular has
certainly tried to cultivate a specific
image and to release the information
that they didn't want it all right
Charlotte North Carolina is next go
ahead please yes good evening hi bios
question first of all comment um I feel
that one of the reasons the President
Reagan didn't do as well against Vice
President Ma noticed was the fact that
he or against a versus what he did
against Carter in 1980 was the fact that
he didn't have access to through Carter
briefed to the briefing papers this is
the story that kind of died and it's
kind of kind of laid back in the back
headlines I haven't heard too much about
it but I feel about that may have been a
contributing factor because it is the
fact that the briefing book did get into
the hands of the Reagan campaign now how
I got there is a different matter it
could have gotten there by any number of
ways and certainly there's no reason to
accuse anybody of any criminal
wrongdoing until something is found out
about it
but that's one story like the your guest
to comment on and the other ISM I
believe that the press is not as liberal
as people maybe people perceive it to be
non give an example on the day after
for our congressman Ferraro gave her
conference I guess over an hour with
about 200 news journalists read the New
York Times and in The New York Times
I found you more cool you know it was
very critical of her you know is still
being very critical I've heard there was
story after story about bringing up this
or that or the other and I know I know
senator Helms here for North Karen is
always quoting like the New York time is
the bastion of liberal journalism and so
forth and I don't know I just perceived
that that there is a unique balance of
journalism and once one final question
did did the Jew guests get to read I
believe Jody Powell's book the other
side and what is his comment about that
thank you okay thank you very much let
me start with the briefing book story
that was of course a summer ago and it
was by far the most thoroughly reported
story of that of that particular summer
called in in several places briefing
book gate as I as I recall I think that
that there was an investigation and that
that the people within the the
government and also within the press
found that it did not lead to to all
that much I think that there were other
problems last week with the preparation
and execution by the President of the of
the debate now the the point about the
the Jody Powell book I think that that
that's a very interesting book and one
that certainly raises the issues that
are in front of us this evening when we
talk about the responsibilities of
journalism because what he does is take
specific examples from his experience in
the Carter White House when the when
reporters would would act in a way that
he considered unethical talks about them
and of more value he talks in general
about the the attitudes and the actions
of the of the press I think it's a book
that's well worth reading Austin Texas
is next go ahead
hi there hi little bit we want to know
what's going on we don't want anybody to
cover up Thank You Austin Texas I agree
with her wholeheartedly I would like to
see a realistic portrait of this country
in this world in in our in our
journalism my point at the very
beginning was what questions are asked
of me most frequently and in an audience
in a general audience the question is
usually why is there so much bad news my
sense is that given the c-span audience
which is an audience that's much more
attentive to two world affairs and to
what's happening that they are able and
not only able but very willing to to
debate some of these controversies guest
is Professor Robert small he in addition
to being the editor of a book to be
published tomorrow by the universe the
University of Notre Dame press the
responsibilities of journalism is an
assistant professor of American Studies
at the University next call for him is
from Indianapolis go ahead please hi
welcome to Indiana thank you I would
like to make three quick
analogies I'm not sure that they fit the
current political situation or not and
then come back to the first one and
relate that to the media
okay the first one deals with the image
that Reagan process presents kind of as
a Superman and I wonder if that might be
part of the reason children tend to
believe what they see on television even
though it's not necessarily real and I
think the debate recently helped destroy
part of that Reagan Superman image and
there was a cartoon I think I saw on
c-span that showed super Reagan going
into the telephone booth and coming out
in the kind of a moth-eaten sweater the
second one he is a Aesop's fable about
the contest between the Sun and the wind
to see who could make the traveler take
off his coat I think of that every time
I hear about building up arms to make
the other side disarm because the wind
the harder the wind blew the less the
man that was paddling wanted to take off
his coat and the third one is a little
story I won't relate it but I'll just
give the reference and that is in
Ecclesiastes 9 13 through 18 and I'll
summarize by saying wisdom is better
than strength or wisdom is better than
weapons of war going back to the first
one I was listening to the radio this
afternoon and I think it was the program
called the Illinois press review on
radio station WI ll and they were or
someone made the point that the press
was making a an issue of Reagan's age
and I thought oh well I didn't think it
was the press making that but maybe the
press has contributed to that and I'm
not really sure they should but maybe
they should and I guess I'm undecided
about that and I'd be interested in
whatever comments have to give them
thank you so I think the the age story
is a classic example of what one could
call echo chamber journalism
where it starts in this case it started
on the front page of The Wall Street
Journal on on Tuesday and then began to
reverberate through the echo chamber of
the of the news media and by the end of
the week yet it certainly had been
talked about by by everyone whether it's
a legitimate issue I'm not sure of that
I am sure that it will probably be on
our minds through the rest of this
campaign what do you think people are
most affected by the local news programs
or the national news programs in making
their decision I don't think that you
can make that sort of distinction I
think on in terms of local affairs that
the the local stations are much more
significant in terms of national I'm
sure that the national are there's a
paradox that all of these players about
confidence in institutions reveal that
there is a low level of confidence about
the the United States Congress and yet
when you go back to the districts the
individual Congress people re-elected in
most cases the incumbents returned to
the to the Congress so that some people
have said that in the national news
you have negativism and cynicism and
that creates this general negative
impression but at home it's a different
story Philadelphia go ahead I'd like to
submit two areas for the professor to
address one is internationally I'm not
sure that the professor's team in the
movie called under-fire involved in
correspondence and press people in South
Americans Somoza situation and I was
wondering how he felt if that depicted a
realistic or a factual presentation of
how the press would behave in that type
of situation okay I'm afraid I haven't
seen it I've only read the the reviews
and the commentary about it basically
from what I got out of the person we
were like
movie was that instead of going down
there they lost objectivity and got
involved in the story correct became
more of a problem than reporting the
problem right and I submit that that's
probably a larger problem
the press is willing to admit in all
areas but to be prefer or electronic in
the other area like to for you to
address is how do you as a journalist or
former journalist miss were we're not
see what the media has been doing
election wise it turned almost the
entire national elections into a big
quiz show can you top this or right haha
I got to you or two points today
tomorrow and we just wondered how the
press can insult the American people's
intelligence because I feel there's a
lot of people that believe did I talk to
that the credibility the press is about
ten scale right politics in America has
always been something of a sport
something of a game but since the
introduction of television into into our
politics it has become a large spectator
sport and I guess I fear more the way in
which television has changed the
institution of politics change the way
that people go about campaigning change
the role of the parties change the the
impact of the the conventions I'm more
fearful of that than I really am of the
individual effects on the the individual
voters I think that the people out there
are intelligent enough to to see through
certain people but now we've reached a
point where it's it's all media politics
and you you schedule your campaign you
conduct your campaign you do everything
for the sake of this news media the
subject is journalism and its
responsibility to its consumers I guess
and the next call is from here southbend
go ahead good evening hi this may be
little provincial but it may help other
people who have newspapers with that
they feel have the same problem I find
that my newspaper is being increased in
price and I am getting more advertising
and much less hard news and especially
in the South Bend Tribune I find if I
did not read the editorial pages I
probably would not know what was going
on in the world because it's only the
colonists that write that allude to
things that have happened and I think oh
this really happened but it had never
appeared in the South Bend treatment
even the local editors write about
things that I know were never on the
pages of the Tribune for instance we
spent two weeks in Canada and we read in
newspapers all across Canada and I knew
more about the United States and
international affairs even reading small
papers than I did about reading the
Tribune and I find I'm very boxed in I
feel boxed in here that I cannot get out
if I do not read news magazines or an
outside paper Detroit Chicago and I
wondered what we can do to pressure the
Tribune to give us factual news and a
related larger scope of news I think the
best way of dealing with a situation
like that is to make your voice heard
and one of the one of the points that
that I raised in this in this book is
that so many people think that the media
out there isn't doesn't really care
about about them that that they're
remote that they're distant and what we
can do as individuals as part of the
public is to reduce the distance and to
to make the news media more accountable
and more responsible and one place to
start would be in direct communication
with them and I would suggest that maybe
that would be the approach to take
Memphis Tennessee with professor Robert
small go ahead yeah doing just fine how
are you just fine I was just curious as
to whether or not your guest his family
thing reported in the news regarding
Mondale's medical records
I had several things that I have one
about why why they haven't appeared in
oppression one of course was a was that
plus they more than in-depth study into
the question Mondale was asked that he
didn't respond to which was why so many
young people were leaving the Democratic
Party and going into the Republican
Party course I have my ideas but I
haven't seen anything in the news that
would try to try to answer that question
for him and I just wonder if you think
such a thing
I've seen some coverage of the of the
medical records and the the profile of
Walter Mondale the main point from all
of that information is that he has a
high blood pressure problem for which he
takes three pills every day I think that
that that story has been reported and
that that the information is out there
for for us I guess Robert small
professor at the University of Notre
Dame and as we're slightly more than
halfway through this hour let me repeat
the phone numbers for you we've got a
few lines open and as we have gone
through a lot of calls area code to on
nine two three four to seven eight eight
for Hoosiers Indiana residents and
everybody else area code 202 three four
to seven for oh and the subject is
almost anything regarding journalism and
what motivated you to edit the book and
to hold the conference the Notre Dame
has always been very involved in in
journalism to one degree or another
and certainly our heritage is one that
that emphasizes the more moral values of
any institution or any undertaking and
it seemed to be a perfect match to bring
several prominent people from diverse
fields to the campus to talk for a
couple of days later to go back and to
ruminate and to come up with the essays
that are in this book okay mishawaka
indiana go ahead about the news media in
general sure first of all i think you
get to degree that the primary
responsibility of the news media is to
is a fair and accurate picture of what's
going on in the world of this fax and
first question is do you think the news
media creates that is served this
disservice to the public by maybe hiking
up an even out of proportion my second
question is do you think that the news
media has some unwritten code of ethics
and they do like this code of ethics be
take the last one first they have a
written code of ethics for the Society
of Professional Journalists and in the
book we talk about the the various codes
and guidelines that that do exist and I
think that they're useful as standards
as talking points let the people within
the profession know about responsible
activity so that exists and it's out
there and in fact people are more
concerned about it now than they than
they ever have been I think that there
is the danger a very real danger of
going too far with the story I would
claim that in many cases that the
coverage of Geraldine Ferraro went too
far and that you have you have really an
effect almost a pendulum effect of
swinging from a coronation and then
swinging back to a crucifixion all
within a very very short period of time
and what's lacking in all that is
perspective proportion and I think it's
a danger that that we run today
particularly because of the intense
competition for Lauderdale Florida is
next go ahead yes I just wanted to
mention that Jim underlings well I
wondered if anyone noticed that can
answer all the questions it was one on
if she was president about verification
keeping up with the depressions we're
doing what they were supposed to do if
they had any kind of an agreement and
she just left that up and said she
wanted to talk about something else
things she did
I don't know whether any of you have
written or read neither the spike or man
in bow my arnaud de Burgos and Robert
Moss these are two very well in my mind
I think they're very wonderful writers
especially our non-diverse Grove he was
on crossfire and I wonder too if you had
seen him at the time he on crossfire
with Buchanan and Tom Hayden Buchanan
being the conservative Braden the very
liberal from the Washington Post and he
mentioned at the time while he was
discussing his Bookman embolden spike
and he mentioned at the time about the
Miami Herald down here which is terribly
liberal and they seem to go after Reagan
terribly
now and then they'll have James
Fitzpatrick with anything that's really
just immoral and excuse me caller do you
have a question coming up in here that
mr. small could answer regarding the
press I just want to mention that the
NBC ABC and CBS that I have noticed do
not tell the truth on many times like
Walter Cronkite on the refugee question
and Newsweek that I quit I used to
subscribe to for years and they weren't
telling the truth I found out many
things that I checked out later but I
read neither or that Russian jr. I just
gave them up entirely okay so I think
there is an awful lot of liberal bias
and and I bet to that man who wondered
about Reagan never been investigated on
the under on American Activities never
as a matter that he thought the
communist in when he was headed up the
Union and
okay now I think you've given us
something to work with let's let
professor small respond to that do you
think the networks are by and large
believed despite her own profession that
she doesn't believe them I think that by
and large they are I think that in the
perception of many people they have
become too arrogant that they that they
set the agenda and that that they really
are more actors than reporters and take
take an example and it's one that
bothers me and that is the use of the
polling information before the closing
of polls on Election Day now this the
academic research thus far is diverse
and conflicting and there's nothing
really nothing has been proved but the
perception in the mind of the public is
that the revelation of that information
before the closing of the polls affects
the turnout could affect a race
presidential race any other kind of race
my sense is that the the networks could
could do a great service to this country
and also erase some of this perception
of arrogance just by some restraint on
something as simple as that I don't
think that's too much I don't know I
don't know there's certainly a great
deal of concern about it okay South Bend
Indiana
go ahead hi you're on the air man okay
I'll turn off this TV when the media
reports that there is a vote by Congress
against a bill or if there's a veto by
the president
wouldn't be especially against health
and welfare and education and so forth
shouldn't the media also report on the
writer that has been attached to that
bill because often I feel that it's the
writer that's responsible for the boat
against or the detail okay thank you man
this is kind of reporting on conscience
think that's very interesting question I
would say yes certainly if it's if it's
a bill that has a tremendous impact or
could be very influential we should know
the reason behind the that decision and
our newspapers and television ought to
tell us that give it a letter grade on
how the press reports on these different
areas of our lives the presidency
mm be be - a Congress see the courts BB
- business probably about a seat class
itself probably about a D why several
reasons for that one is that people
within the media think it's it's it's
inside media or you know inside baseball
but people out there aren't interested
in in what they do their job is to
report about other people that that
would be the the standard line the other
is and I think more to the point is that
people within the news media have fairly
thin skins and if you begin to write
especially in a critical way about the
media you're gonna lose your friends at
the neighborhood go ahead how is it that
you know all these liberal candidates
are going down to Alabama to see mr.
Wallace okay fair question
thank you I'm not mistaken the the
Communist Party has a slate of its own
in this election and I don't believe
that the Civil Liberties Union has
taking a stand on on it I would say
about governor Wallace that much of that
is is his own doing rather than the than
the people who have paid him a visit
that he has moved in a different
direction during the past few years
getting back to your letter grades
earlier the White House greater I know
that because the White House press corps
is huge sure yet you gave the press a
very low grade for the reason I'm giving
it a low grade is I think that it could
could do more in the way of in the way
of illuminating us about the
administration and Ronald Reagan and
what he's doing and all of that to me
they at time seemed to be captives of
the administration PR department they
work against that and I think that's all
to their credit and you get these pieces
CBS just a few nights ago had one that
that this whole campaign has been
structured for for television and we're
presenting that to you just so you know
that I think they can they can get
behind the image okay arrey
next call pardon me plymouth indiana go
ahead yeah a quick question this band
when you're coming into a town like
south band how do you get set up for
what you're going to do so far it looks
kind of like notre dame is well we have
a producer come in work over the last
couple weeks to look around and see what
there is and get a sense of the
community I think that you're right we
have had some large Notre Dame presence
but I think you'll see also some more
presence as we're here the rest of the
time okay the question I had he alluded
to a little bit earlier with the
arrogance of the president perceived
there against the depressed in the
Westmoreland case coming up you think
there's a tendency for a backlash with a
jury
that maybe smack the hand of the network
and say don't do this anymore
excellent question and I think you're
you're probably right that there may
well be a backlash it's not only CBS on
trial it's the news media in the United
States and there has been and there will
be so much attention about this trial
that that people are going to make
judgments about the the news media based
on it
much too early of course to to render a
judgment about the about the case but
from everything that that I've been able
to read and to to learn about it we are
going to find out some practices of CBS
that are not in the the most responsible
fashion you know we still haven't heard
any calls from any working journalists
either print or electronic and we've
still got no less than ten minutes to
hear from them if they're out there so
I'll repeat the numbers one more time
area code two one nine two three four to
seven eight eight if you live in Indiana
and everybody else can call it area code
202 be edited well to be technical maybe
a couple hours from now it's a edited or
published on Monday University of Notre
Dame press and I think it's $13.95 next
call for you professor is from Michigan
City Michigan and go ahead or Indiana
pardon me
yes Michigan City yeah great I'd like to
start by saying that c-span is terrific
and I think we're lucky in Michigan City
to have a super paper in the news
dispatch I think that there is a bias in
the press and I think it's against
conservative movements and politicians
like President Reagan I'll cite a couple
quick examples and I'd be pleased to
have your guests comment on them the
first is a survey that was taken by
American Enterprise Institute in 1980 it
was published in public opinion magazine
just a few thoughts about the evidence
that the journalists do seem they have a
left-leaning bias in the inner voting
patterns at least in seventy two fifty
two percent of the electorate voted for
Nixon 81% of the media voted for
McGovern in 76 the leading journalist
pick hard over for by exactly the same
margin
I'm sorry in this case it was 81 to 19
percent card over for it the last
statistic in 1966 87 percent of the
media it
LEED chose Humphrey over Nixon and I and
again that's way disproportionate to
what the way the public voted next I
noticed that it I am a Reagan supporter
but it did seem that I'll agree that
Mondale won the debate last Sunday
however and then there was just an
avalanche of information analysis of
that debate which I think was fair game
but in the debate Thursday night I think
that Bush was a clear winner there was
some quantitative evidence of that in
the USA Today poll and also in the ABC
polls the public thought that Bush won
convincingly however if you looked at
the ABC coverage of their own poll that
night and also on Nightline that evening
there was it was a draw at best
also if you watched Washington
Washington we can review on PBS all the
journalists on a program called it at
least to draw again in a great
disproportionate analysis compared to
what the public thought last quick
comment you're a gas mentioned that he
thought a 60-minute primetime news
program would be excellent I'd agree
with that there is one now that is
available to most of us on PBS and
that's the macneil-lehrer report I'd be
interested in how he perceives that and
if he knows what are the ratings for
McClure car don't go away tell it you
seem pretty pretty much a heavy consumer
of the news yes I'm afraid I'm kind of a
kind of an information junkie I think
I'm not a working journalist I'm a
working CPA but I love to follow
politics and what the press has to say
about it okay well thank you very much
for the call
professor great let me let me start with
the first point and that is the the
study that you cite about the liberal
tendencies of the of the news media I
think you're right in that particular
study the the journalist certainly
seemed in their daily life to to be
quite quite liberal I would hope though
that that the business would would have
about it some professionalism and that
if they did have biases that they would
try to be fair and balanced in in their
coverage to a large extent I think they
are fair and balanced or at least they
they try to be decided I think
it's easy to cite an example 1980
senator Kennedy and the way that he
became involved in the in the campaign
and there was certainly certainly a high
level of of criticism of him from from
journalists from the so-called liberal
journalists I think they saw a good
story and and went with it I think that
certainly the the business of the
Ferraro bush debate the public did think
that the George Bush won that's fine
that's all well and good I tho think
could be more important to to learn a
little bit more about the issues raised
by the the two candidates ok Peoria
Illinois is next okay I'm gonna turn my
TV down all right we haven't wanted to
ask what I'm for all the media it's
better than living in Russia and the
government putting out their facts and
everything and if the American people
haven't got a mind of their own that
they can pick up what is really going on
now during the debate you saw what you
got nobody has to tell us that Reagan
plundered and Mondale came on top those
are the facts and people better quit
trying to make all kinds of excuses now
about the press being so liberal I'm
just wondering how many calls are coming
out of this very far Welles group that
are programmed so much to call in
against the Liberals what's wrong with
them look for liberals we're American
people we have a right to think the way
we want to think and I'm for of the
press I'm all for Steve and I'm all for
Americanism that doesn't make me a
communist okay ma'am well said and and I
think she raises a very important point
what whatever I have said and whatever
might be in that book you
not meant to be critical of the idea of
a free press in this country too many of
us loved it too many of us would would
do anything to to fight for it
and all we're saying is that it we've
reached a time when the power and the
influence is so great that the people
who were involved in in journalism
should remember the the ethics of their
business and go about their work in a
responsible fashion
is it possible to regulate it even in a
little bit I would I would hope that
would never be the case I think that the
the mechanisms for regulation are in
broadcasting the FCC and in the news
media in general the courts let's leave
it there but let's also be as
responsible as we can in in going about
our daily business professor Robert
small we're almost out of time this is
your book the responsibilities of
journalism edited this book and it's
available from the Notre Dame press
Notre Dame Indiana four six five five
six
that's zip code one more time four six
five five six it's been an interesting
hour thank you very much for being with
us thank you for having me and this
concludes this day's stop of grassroots
84 at South Bend Indiana
thank you for watching we'd also like to
thank budget rent-a-cars for being with
us here in South Bend as they have been
around the rest of the country on our
tour across the country have a good
evening
[Music]
[Music]